dos días después de las elecciones Por
fin se pronunció el presidente saliente
de Jair bolsonaro y lo hizo justamente
en solamente dos minutos en los que dijo
varias cosas por un lado afirmó que pese
a lo que dicen sus detractores él es un
hombre de democracia y seguirá
respetando la Constitución Aunque nunca
en su discurso mencionó a Lula da Silva
o que concedía la derrota sin embargo
después de finalizar ese concretó que sí
se hará el cambio de Mando presidencial
bolsonaro sin embargo también es
disculpó de cierta manera los bloqueos
de camioneros en más de 20 estados del
país diciendo que estas manifestaciones
son resultado de la injusticia electoral
a la salida de bolsonaro llegó el
ministro de la casa a presidenciales
sino nogueira para afirmar que dará
inicio a este proceso de cambio de Mando
que tendrá efecto a partir del primero
de enero cuando llegue concretamente
Lula de a Silva a Brasilia para ello da
Silva ha nombrado a Gerardo alkin su
vicepresidente para liderar a un equipo
de unas 50 personas para que harán todo
este proceso para recibir a los
bolsonaristas los documentos y procesos
pertinentes en el tema de otra parte se
pronunció la misión electoral de la oea
la organización de los Estados
Americanos que no solamente felicitó a
la participación de los órganos
encargados de llevar a cabo el proceso
electoral sino que felicitó a la
ciudadanía que Salió masivamente a votar
y aquí viene el dato normalmente la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones en
Brasil Presenta una mayor abstención sin
embargo este año se rompió la tendencia
en segunda vuelta hubo una abstención de
20,5%. y en primera vuelta fue de 20,9%
y pues como sabíamos muy bien cada voto
en esta elección en la que el ganador se
eligió solamente por dos millones y poco
más de votos era muy importante